DC Comics there was a time above
let me ask everyone a question if every
screenwriter grows up being cold enough
to put narration in their movie unless
it enhances the story then why does
every screenwriter put narration that
doesn't enhance the story into their
screenplays for the third time in three
Batman franchises we get the dead parent
origin story I guess they did try to
warn us at the beginning also this is
the type of theater that plays the 1940
film the Mark of Zorro but also coming
soon because this is 1981 after all
Excalibur Zack the public has already
seen Bruce Wayne's parents death several
times yes but have they seen it in slow
motion
Bruce falls into a hole that would kill
most people and he's not Batman yet and
you be the Batcave if he wanted to steal
the pearls why'd he intentionally got
the necklace by pulling this gun bolt
now I'll have to pick them out of the
rich people blood over goddamn you so
slow goddamn motion no remember this it
will become inexplicably and
infuriatingly important later
King what also confidence-building back
tornado a beautiful lie Ben Affleck
describes this movie in one sentence yep
no way the film could have started here
we definitely needed to rehash his
parents death in order to understand
this totally in the middle of all this
bull Bruce really thought it was a good
idea to take a private helicopter into
Metropolis for some reason here is Bruce
Wayne landing in Metropolis and
immediately getting into his private
vehicle a Jeep King renegade the very
definition of a common middle class
vehicle I see one of these things at
every goddamn stoplight Bruce Wayne
would be driving a Tesla or the very
least a BMW but not a goddamn Jeep yes
the sequence of Bruce experiencing the
carnage of Man of Steel's climax is
interesting it's also revisionist
history by the man who took too
personally the criticism that Man of
Steel killed too many innocent people
so whatever mobile network these people
are using is apparently alien attack
proof and here I lose my signal when I'm
under an umbrella I want you to get
everyone out of the building right now
Jack besides just now is the appropriate
time to evacuate makes you think he has
to ask Bruce's approval to go to the
bathroom Bruce Wayne alone running into
the fray while everyone else panics yeah
even in a movie the I'm duty-bound to
remove sins for something so badass do
you think also good King eyesight to
spot mr. Wayne at that distance in a
dust cloud this guy's trapped underneath
one single girder like a whole building
just fell and apparently the only Robo
is a lot of dust and a couple girders in
the middle of a dust cloud from ground
level and without any visual enhancement
gear on how the hell can Bruce clearly
see these two fighting he barely saw the
girl right next to him little girl who
lost her mother stands here waiting for
Bruce Wayne Hux because she knows how
close the Wayne logo sign is and how
cool a shot it will make
Hans Zimmer's finger gets stuck on the
Dom button the somewhere is implied by
simply saying it's the Indian Ocean all
it takes to get the most precious
element on earth is a couple free divers
with a motorboat and a dream is that
ever explained how this Kryptonian
vessel full of kryptonite crash-landed
in Indian fucking ocean also kryptonite
in case you confused it with Nairobi
Judd oh hey it's Jimmy Olsen the
grounding moral center in this universe
of superhero pretense man I really hope
he gets a lot of screen time somehow
they're gonna be able to blame Superman
for all these headshots because if
there's anything Superman needs it's a
gun Superman shows up out of nowhere
because I guess he can sense when Lois
is in danger don't give me that he was
following the beacon craft because if he
was really interested in all this he'd
already be there the world has been so
caught up with what Superman can do that
no one has asked what he should do this
is a direct ripoff of Jeff Goldblum
Jurassic Park quote and the writer
should be ashamed uh if I had a nickel
for every time I fingered a bullet well
naked we'll just assume Clark took his
phone out his pocket before this because
otherwise Superman is a dick to
smartphones I don't understand even in a
different language the pronoun game
never ceases to hilariously confuse I
mean how do you build this luxurious
bachelor pad without skilled contractors
who you then either need to pay off or
kill my biggest issue with any Batman
story actually someone explain to me how
Alfred and Bruce alone designed and
built this please hurry Bob our final
fairy bottom off funnel fairy butter bar
must be the English equivalent of
siblings feels like Bruce would have
been wise to Superman in his secret
identity long ago being the best
detective in the world and all but this
movie would have you believe that Wayne
really only got interested in this guy
after he helped destroy a whole city
maybe these eggs would be in better
shape a holy shield a wall of wrenches
and tools just off the kitchen and
behind the TV and next year upside down
bike Jesus are you Matthew McConaughey
the first victim an accused child
predator later was assaulted in prison
many believe the mark of the bat brand
in prison essentially is a death
sentence what a bunch of bull someone
can make that observation after that
huge sample size of one person got beat
up in prison and don't child molesters
usually get beaten in jail anyway I've
smelled manufacture attention welcome to
LexCorp which apparently rebuilt
metropolis in 18 months based on tons of
money hard work and either the dragon
tears of unicorn angels or the aliens
from Jupiter ascending
nerdy Lex is introduced being nerdy on
the basketball court yet still nailing a
three-pointer like Steph Curry I hate
this priority finally a movie put so
many newspaper headlines and stories in
one shot and with such
tiny print I don't care to actually go
digging for mistakes Touche movie I'm
glad this guy helpfully underlined and
boxed mentions of Superman on these
newspaper headlines or else he might
have gotten them confused with articles
about Captain America or Dwayne the rock
Johnson Superman statue does not depict
Superman twisting Zod's neck but I guess
that's kind of hard to curve in rock
yeah do sports today because newspaper
writers play musical chairs with the
kinds of stories they write on a daily
basis headline end of love affair with
men the sky Mary whites editorial style
is to literally dictate headlines to his
writers and ask them to write stories
that match you know I like Jesse
Eisenberg
but this Lex Luthor is - Jesse Eisenberg
is that a kryptonite scalpel how does
Lex know he needs a fingerprint who
knows he just knows mmm nine and a half
weeks looks like basically everyone has
been breaking fight clubs first two
rules crime wave and Gotham other
breaking news water wet okay Perry White
is basically just a dick dismissing a
story about a vigilante in Gotham as
completely unused worthy while asking
for an update on a story about football
I can't both stories be interesting to
the public I'm blocking the import
license for your mineral something I
could have just called to tell you you
can call me whatever you like take a
bucket of piss and call it grand HPT
aside from being a fantastically stupid
line it's made even worse by only being
here to give us some kind of suppose a
payoff later at the hearing but most of
all what the fuck does that even mean
are you the bucket of piss in this
analogy also surprisingly granny's peach
tea was the only company that turned
down the promotional tie-in with Batman
V Superman oh this is a dream I mean any
other movie the slow motion would have
served as warning
second dream sequence is necessary to
show how tough Bruce is but including
yet another jump scare is necessary to
show what an asshole this movie is you
know it balls like yours you belong in
here that's racist well Bruce Wang can't
break into Lex Luthor's house Bruce
Wayne right half Jim he's been invited
how fortuitous and not as exciting a
movie that would have been much better
than this is given me your Easter egg
treatment because that's fun is that
seriously Clark Kent does not know who
Bruce Wayne is gotta hear this room that
no one should enter is easily accessible
by simply pushing open the door not the
bathroom was down here I must have Bruce
Wayne dares to try this and she pretends
to believe it and Bruce seems to think
it got away with it all of which is
ridiculous after following him and
checking on him and hearing his flimsy
ass excuse this Luther security chick
leaves him alone in the compute
what the fuck I like how Clarke heard
Bruce's radio communications but did
nothing to investigate it
Superman is lazy Bruce Wayne meets Clark
Kent looks Luthor knows why this would
be a momentous occasion but God help you
if you want an explanation for why he
knows what nobody else does oh wow that
is a good grip you should not pick a
fight with this person again I have no
idea if it was the script the director
or the actor who decided this character
needed to be this far over the top but
it was a bad decision okay she took his
thing and obviously wants him to know
because she hangs around to get caught
staring at him right outside the door
but then she leaves without telling him
anything so what gives
this is whack-ass behavior Superman
Jesus 90% of people believe in a higher
power and I'm gonna need a source on
that statistic dude on this earth every
act is a political act even twerking
international bloggers are there no
journalists and experts left in this
reality willing to go on cable news or
is this the movie just giving the finger
to the internet community that dislike
Manta steel I'm glad Superman saved
these astronauts but this scene is
really pessimistic about the state of
space travel and successful rocket
launches know using Neil deGrasse Tyson
for your own personal projects this
family literally managed to get to the
roof with their bodies and some white
paint and that's it no sandwiches or
nothing and while I'm not sure that one
can of paint would be enough to paint
this giant ass Superman logo I'm more
concerned with the logic these people
used hey there's a flood everyone get to
the roof and someone grab some paint so
we can make a giant Superman logo on the
roof that if he somehow happens to be in
the area saving lives he won't miss
again another instance of a cool
storyboard trumping logic in a Snyder
film then Superman king hovers for a few
seconds doubtless confused by the huge
white logo before actually saving these
poor assholes this guy who just got
thrown in jail for defacing the Superman
statue and making terrorist threats gets
to have a meeting with the senator
instantly without any security let's
copy all right nothing about food even
though it is ridiculous Clark was told
to write about football and he's doing
the right thing by writing about the
Gotham bat this should have gotten him
fired but he cares about Clark Kent
taking on the Batman
he's right they care about Superman
taking on the Batman of which this movie
titled Batman V Superman has very little
is it stealing if you steal from another
two
yes Bruce Wayne's decryption software
moves at the same pace as my youtube
uploads luckily this decryption will
last just long enough for a holy fucking
unnecessary third 4 minute Batman dream
sequence guy with a gun has a clear shot
of Batman here but the signs instead to
run up to Batman to shake his hand I
guess just to clarify Batman is knocked
unconscious during his own dream and
when he wakes up from that dream he's
going to have another cryptic dream
about a visitor from an unknown future
movie is seriously trying to out dream
inception I'd just like to know how
Bruce is hallucinating the flash right
now giving him important information and
advertising the standalone movie all at
once does Bruce have sue saying powers
Bruce's nightmares lasted exactly as
long as his computer's decryption
process racin if we believe there's even
a 1% chance that he is our enemy we have
to take it as the absolute sir math is
not one of Bruce's strong suits where
does he go why do you continue to employ
him Batman harpoons this car which he
will drag around for a little while
until knowing exactly how to unhook it
so that it will land on another car
hiding behind a trailer something he
definitely knew was going to happen when
he harpoon the car in the first place
Superman who definitely knew some was
going down here tonight didn't bother to
simply talk to Batman before all this
started essentially you're telling me
he's omniscient enough to be here he's
omniscient enough to save a rocket from
an explosion for chrissake but decided
to enter the scene at this very moment
because it's better for the drama also
why not do this out of the gate instead
of spending weeks or months
investigative journalism in Batman as
Clark Kent it takes an hour and four
minutes for Batman to be Superman in a
much more realistic feeling movie this
Batcave entrance will somehow top Burton
and Schumacher for silliness how do we
determine what's good a question the
makers of this movie clearly never asked
themselves
Superman visits Kansas at the perfect
time the world's planetarium is open
somebody wanna turn around and look
guilty I'm still not sure how blowing
away a whole bunch of dudes with special
bullets is supposed to implicate
Superman so story reeks of bullshit but
how could they know that he'd show up in
the middle of the desert
Lois asks a very good question that is
never answered in fact the only thing
she's concerned about in this revelation
is that Superman is going to show up at
the Capitol building and she suspect
something's about to go down but the how
does Superman know to show up in the
right place question is better left
answered by other movies in the Justice
League franchise once the screenwriters
come up with a good enough excuse how
did he know when she'd spot the label on
her glass to be able to time this bomb
blast you know it's not that Superman is
angry it's just that he's disappointed
movie skips over what would have been a
much more entertaining Batman breaks in
a lexcorp's scene to give a Superman
walking through the Capitol into a
courtroom
how does Lex know there's a pool of
water who's on the ship and how does he
know standing in it not only won't kill
it'll do something amazing to the body
of Zod Lex's omniscient enough that I
wonder why he struggles against Superman
and Batman at all actually even though
he got in the front door using Zhaan's
fingerprints Lex only has to press his
own palm on the receiver to get the ship
to respond it's telling that versus
CrossFit routine is the fourth most
enjoyable part of this movie Bruce is
addictive weights Alexander Luthor your
security override has been accepted but
why I feel like this movie has skipped
over some integral parts of storytelling
here just accept this just accept that
you came here to make doomsday fine
we'll help you do that this water-based
Kryptonian King Star Trek replicator of
all knowledge and science yeah okay get
hard I really hate it and it's stupid
that it exists and even stupider that
Luthor figures it all out okay so with a
little bit of Luthor's blood mixed with
Zod's dead body and some sort of DNA
pool of Justice Lex will be able to make
a monster out of it knew the spaceship
had this kind of ability why would a
spaceship have this kind of ability the
set of Superman movies is obsessed with
dead father's giving Clark advice Misha
son no you don't you're dead
why doesn't Superman have the same in
trouble radar for his mom that he seems
to have for Lois yeah I'll set my bat
booby trap right here blocks if not
miles from the start of my fight with
Superman because I know for a fact I can
direct the fight back to this spot for a
wedding
ladies and gentlemen Gotham the
metropolis star mile apart you're
welcome also it is just across the bay
but while Gotham is having torrential
rain and storms the weather in
Metropolis is just peachy Lois in danger
in the Middle East or later in this
climax when trapped in a box
Superman hears it above all the noise of
the world Lois is kidnapped Superman
hears nothing stupid triangle inequality
the shortest distance between any two
points I mentioned how much I hate this
version of Lex Luthor because I do
spewing random does not equal menacing
also fYI we are right at the start of
the film's climax with still an hour
left to go oh look he can hear her
falling but he couldn't hear her being
kidding out the last 30 minutes of her
life what a selective power Superman
just leaves Lois here what we call God
depends upon our tribe Clark Joe
Superman let's Lex talk long enough for
Lex to reveal he's got Clark's mom
instead of just obliterating him
instantly as he should have and would
have really done God versus man
oh come on Martha Martha Martha do I
consider this Martha Martha Martha
foreshadowing considering what comes
later break a bunch foreshadowing really
also Lex goes to the trouble to make
individual Polaroids because scrolling
through pictures on his phone would take
too long yeah don't you know I mean you
seem to find Louis no problem do you
only have a homing beacon on her
LexCorp new to make these files almost
like teaser trailers it's amazing their
marketing department collect miles Dyson
still hasn't learned his lesson about
not creating terminators even after he
died in the second movie and forget the
heliport put it on the goddamn roof okay
even though it's weird that the helipad
isn't already on the roof what
difference would it make
let's talk about Batman's plan sure
Superman told him next time they shine
your light in the sky don't go to it
there are numerous problems with this
though first off did Bruce forget that
Superman was in hiding after the Capitol
building bombing did he really think
their petty squabble was going to lure
him out second off this plan wasn't even
going to work until Lex kidnapped Martha
and told Superman to go fight Batman
there's an alternate history of the
movie where Batman lies in wait for
Superman and he never shows up like that
date I had in college and we had plans
Melissa Bruce when did these assholes
learn each other's secret identity was
it at the party did they just assume but
here's the rub Lex Luthor also has to
know that both Superman and Batman know
each other secret identities for his
plan to work if flex tells Superman to
kill Batman
and if Batman isn't lying in wait for
Superman at this moment and Superman has
to find Bruce Wayne and that's if he
knows Batman is Bruce that's a lot of
ifs you don't understand we'll find that
Superman will waste a lot of time with
the listen to me and you don't
understand instead of just saying what
the problem is not sure what these
machine guns were supposed to do but Wow
shiny excitement oh good more of this ah
kryptonite the unfortunate repetitive
writer's crutch that plagues nearly all
Superman movies how much does this miss
diminish Superman's powers we have no
idea and are never told though it's safe
to assume it's enough to make a Batman
Superman fight viable which I would
think would mean a lot
he's this debilitated by the Kryptonite
gas just kill his ass right now what are
you waiting for
oh yeah kryptonite gas it wears off
apparently even though it's completely
inside Superman's lungs not even though
aura Batman can stop Superman I'm
confused
the Wayne in pain chooses mainly to
complaint oh look Batman was totally
able to leave the battle to this spot
even though that's goddamn impossible it
might be the stupidest thing in this
movie which is saying something
Omar oh god damn it
first off who calls their mother by the
real name in this situation this is
maybe the biggest scene in the whole
movie second off god damn it because
Clark and Bruce both have mothers named
Martha Batman decides to let Superman
live and goddamn at third Martha is a
common name Martha is a common name
you're telling me that at the mere
mention of Martha Batman gets all
sentimental
Martha Parkers yeah yeah we know we
heard Thomas the comedian Wayne st.
Martha out loud earlier in the movie we
saw the earlier dream sequence this
movie's seventeenth such occurrence
where it showed Martha Wayne's tombstone
we know his mother's name is Martha get
on with it just in case this movie isn't
long enough for you we got a recap of
the first five minutes why did you say
that guy exactly his mother's name it
took Lois Lane to fly here in a
helicopter for some reason to finally
tell him that really that slow is his
only function for flying out here he's
for stupid like this but don't worry it
gets stupider he wanted your life ours
now that they fought Superman suddenly
comes up with the words he could have
easily said before all the fighting
started hot damn this is Batman
I'm removing three scents for this movie
understanding Batman action better than
any previous even though that's not
nearly close enough to save this film's
final scene total on Sunday sauce I
figured the Cape this is the only moment
of levity in the entire film and that
makes it worth a sin a sin of omission a
character I respect suddenly turned
stupid and throws this crypto spear into
this water thinking that over time no
one will ever find it and so that the
movie will have an ex machina wants
tombs day shows up yeah we'll do it
this is some convenient ask timing here
he just found out his original plan
failed
but his backup plan is literally three
seconds from powering up blood of my
blood
Superman just stands around while he
waits for Luthor to do the next thing
instead of throwing him around the world
50 times are just taking him to jail
barn to destroy you
but how you just cut yourself and put
Zhaan's body you know what the do I
let's just get this over with already oh
good more of this thankfully though the
workday is over in the downtown core
it's nearly empty bull it's funny how
this movie in civil war suddenly started
caring about all the destruction their
heroes were causing and then started
making absolutely sure even though it's
impossible that no one are hardly anyone
is in the area one a woman is getting on
a plane and sees the super fight on the
news but no airplane I've ever been on
gave me live television on the monitors
prior to takeoff so this is a bull and
this doesn't even look like first-class
Strykers Island east of Metropolis
that's uninhabited of course it is
I'm saying it's unkillable and I know
that because I'm sitting in an office
and we've tried one thing to kill it I
gotta get it to chase me back to City
exit - or you could just fly there get
it and fly back either wait really but
go ahead with your he has to chase me
plan I sure am glad they rebuilt
metropolis so the doomsday can destroy
metropolis who knew Wonder Woman's
bracelets can stop all the doomsday
Kryptonian laser beams in the world even
when the total area of said lasers
eclipses the area of said bracelets also
Wonder Woman ex-market up she just got
off the plane was able to dress up get
to the scene and know exactly what to do
just in time also the fight one woman
saw was happening in Metropolis and this
is now happening in Gotham so few movie
even though louis has no idea who
doomsday is or what he does she gets the
bright idea that maybe they need that
crypto sphere after all what did you
bring him back to the city a port is
abandoned
yeah yeah everywhere is abandoned we get
it she would you I thought yours is here
really Bruce you've seen her and
interacted with her half-dozen times at
this point what is this line except
scripted hilarity that doesn't square
with the script and despite numerous
heavy pieces of architecture falling
down in this pool with Lois she survives
this it's actually hard to believe after
seeing Wonder Woman shield and bracelets
perform miracles that she doesn't have a
weapon that can just end this fool this
movie Superman can't just javelin this
thing into doomsday heart he has to
crash into him to do it so that the
movie can have its fake death scene oh
no Superman is dead obey and lasts until
the next movie when they revive him and
move on this possibly be the most
insulting part of the movie the guy who
looks like Superman with glasses died on
the same night as Superman and still no
connection can we even get a Steve
Buscemi scene where we was living in an
apartment surrounded by video screens
soda cans and beef jerky where he makes
the connection I mean Jesus it's a movie
funeral so definitely add some bagpipes
because Superman was so Scottish and
such I failed on WoW actually you ended
up not killing in like you would plan
then when you promised to save his mom
you did that to in spectacular fashion
so you're good here bro we can do better
we will just not with this movie I guess
either Batman got permission from the
warden to do this electric light show
and dramatic branding thing he's about
to do or he just knocked out the guards
to do it either way this is some pretty
unbelievable
he's hungry he's found us who the
you-know-what
there's no way Lex had yet another
monster in mind after making doomsday
and coming up with the plan to get
Batman and Superman to fight you know
that last 10 minutes you just went
through trying to make us think Superman
was dead especially when you're trying
to set up a Justice League movie yeah
that was a total waste
I'm not dead
what nothing is you know inputs I'm not
dead yeah he says he's not dead yes he
is I'm not he isn't well he will be soon
he's very ill getting better no you're
not
I can't stay down here and open as I was
going through some dives I met a man
with seven wives every wife had seven
sacks every sack had seven cat okay sir
your Lebowski I'm a Lebowski that's
terrific
are you God what it's just that the last
time this was here it was being signed
who you were there mission to fight
injustice to right that which is wrong
and to serve all mankind
I close my eyes only for